der klausibär also das schreit nach
Weihnachten hier ne voll lecker
[Musik]
hallo zusammen und willkommen zu einem
weihnachtlichen Video denn heute gibt es
eine Weihnachtstorte von mir eine die
einfach nach Weihnachten schreit und ähm
ich würde sagen ich mache es wie immer
ich fange direkt an weil ich möchte euch
nicht lange warten lassen ich mache
gerade die Böden und dafür trenne ich
jetzt erstmal Eier und wenn ihr euch
jetzt fragt wo stehen denn jetzt die
ganz genau Zutaten die stehen unten in
der Infobox so und wir machen hier wie
gesagt erstmal den Biskuitboden dafür
habe ich hier erstmal Eiweiß in meiner
Schüssel und gebe jetzt die Hälfte des
Zuckers dazu einfach nach Augenmaß keine
große Kunst draus machen bzw jetzt
erstmal 30 Sekunden anschlagen und dann
die Hälfte des Zuckers einrieseln lassen
und gerne schon die Prise Salz mit
dazugeben
[Musik]
so fertig ist unsere sehr sehr feste
Baisermasse das ganze dauert mit der
Maschine jetzt und zweieinhalb bis drei
Minuten wenn den Handrührgerät habt
dauert das einfach nur länger und da
habe ich darauf achten dass es wirklich
richtig schön fest dass ich kann ja
richtig durchschneiden mit dem Messer
und ähm da bleibt nichts hängen das ist
so geil ich liebe das so und jetzt gebe
ich die Schüssel ganz kurz beiseite und
nehme mir die mit dem Eigelb
schneebesenaufsatz bleibt dran speichern
und dann kommt der restliche Zucker dazu
und auch schon das Vanilleextrakt für
den Geschmack und dann wird das auch
noch mal 3 Minuten lang richtig schön
hell cremig geschlagen
[Musik]
das ging jetzt doch schneller als
gedacht also anderthalb Minuten mit der
Maschine und so sieht die Masse aus
richtig schön dick cremig man glaubt gar
nicht dass das Resultat aus einfach nur
eigelb und Zucker ist aber es ist es
du glaubst mir so Maschine kommt weg und
jetzt machen wir folgendes wir nehmen
uns jetzt einen Teigschaber und müssen
die Baisermasse ganz viel Liebe und in
mehreren Schritten unterheben so dass
möglichst wenig Luft entweicht dann
immer in so kreisenden Bewegungen von
außen nach innen
komm mal näher dran guck dir mal diese
vanillepünktchen an
das sieht so geil aus
das wird auf jeden Fall ein richtig
schöner fluffiger Vanille Biskuitboden
und dann habe ich noch einen Anteil aber
nur einen kleinen Anteil an Buttercreme
einfach für die Optik für außen aber es
wird eine leckere Buttercreme und wir
machen noch eine schöne Mascarpone Sahne
Füllung also es wird schon eine richtig
richtig leckere Torte und ich würde auch
den Boden gerne grün färben weil ich
finde Weihnachten muss ich immer an die
Farben Rot und Grün denken und deswegen
dachte ich mir mit dem Anschnitt ist es
dann grün also so die Theorie mal gucken
ob es dann auch alles so aussieht wie
ich mir das vorstelle und außen herum
dann knallrot ich hol gleich ein
bisschen schon meine grüne Farbe raus
weil ich finde jetzt der perfekte
Zeitpunkt das einzufären wenn man hat eh
diese Tränen in Bewegungen und dann kann
man automatisch die Lebensmittelfarbe da
einarbeiten
[Musik]
so also es ist schon man muss schon
richtig viel umrühren und nimmt lieber
ein bisschen zu viel Farbe als zu wenig
weil das ist jetzt nicht so dass
Endergebnis was ja aus dem Ofen bekommt
im Ofen durch das Backen wir jetzt auch
noch mal ein Tacken heller ja daher
nicht geizen bei der Farbe so das alles
hat sich jetzt sehr gut miteinander
verbunden die Farbe gefällt mir sehr gut
und jetzt kommen die trockenen Zutaten
dazu unbedingt sieben und da könnt ihr
auch vorher die drei trockenen Zutaten
mehl Speisestärke und Backpulver einfach
vorab miteinander verrühren damit sich
das besser verbindet und dann auch in
zwei drei Schritten
[Musik]
so Ofen habe ich übrigens auch schon
vorgeheizt falls Backanfänger zuschauen
nahezu bei allen Rezepten muss der Ofen
vorgeheizt sein also nicht dann erst auf
180 Grad Ober- und Unterhitze stellen
wenn ihr den Boden nach also den Kuchen
da rein geht
[Musik]
so und jetzt werde ich meinen Tortenring
ich habe hier den XL Tortenring der ist
besonders hoch also ich habe ja den mit
15 cm Höhe hier gerade es gibt noch
einen noch höheren für besonders hohe
tortenprojekte aber der reicht mir heute
und den werde ich jetzt den Backpapier
einschlagen das gibt ganz einfach viele
stellen sich das mal super schwer vor
ihr nehmt euch dann ausreichend großes
Stück Backpapier und dann legt ihr den
Tortenring mit sich drauf und dann
einfach immer an den Rand knicken immer
so weiter bis ihr am Ende angekommen
seid und ihr könnt dabei damit es
einfacher ist den Tortenring einfach
drehen und dann quasi mit einer Hand den
Tortenring drehen und mit der anderen
Hand das Backpapier einkneten ganz am
Ende einfach nur an den Rand drücken und
dann könnt ihr das auch ganz einfach
annehmen und könnte auch ein bisschen
flüssigere Teige reingeben ohne dass ihr
euch zerläuft und im allerbesten Fall
habt ihr noch eine richtig schöne
schönen geraden Untergrund wie zum
Beispiel ein gelochtes Backblech oder
aber ein emailliertes gratis Backblech
hauptsache es ist gerade und hat nicht
diese Mulde und jetzt fülle ich den Teig
ein den könnt ihr dann an der Oberfläche
noch einigermaßen gerade verstreichen
und dann wird der komplett gar gebacken
also ich hatte gerade noch mehlklümpchen
drin dann einfach hier noch mal schnell
so ein bisschen einarbeiten das ist auch
kein Problem das passiert mal und dann
einfach in den Tortenring einfüllen
[Musik]
guck mal das passiert wenn der Klumpen
drin sind nein weißt du wann das
passiert wenn du an der Seite stehst und
nicht verwirrst kaputt
ist doch voll alles bleibt
so der Boden hat bei mir 46 Minuten lang
gebacken dann war komplett gleich lass
ihn gerade auskühlen und machen jetzt
Zwischenzeit schon mal die erste Creme
das wird unsere Füllung denn ich mache
ja für außen einfach für die Optik
gleich eine leckere Buttercreme aber
möchte einfach innen drin eine leichtere
Creme haben und da eignet sich
Mascarpone immer gut weil Mascarpone
schmeckt halt relativ neutral hat aber
die gewisse eine gewisse Festigkeit so
dass ihr dann relativ hohe Torten
einfach problemlos Schichten können
transportieren könnt ihr müsst euch
keine Sorgen machen dass irgendetwas
weich ist ich gebe jetzt die kalte
Schlagsahne direkt mit dazu alle Zutaten
sind kalt dann funktioniert das
gemeinsame aufschlagen auch so und dann
könnte ich hier auch schon Zucker und
ich mache eine Vanille kokos-torte habe
ich das überhaupt schon erwähnen nein
eigentlich nicht ne Vanille Kokos ist
das Thema heute also kommt jetzt schon
mal Vanilleextrakt mit dazu gleich gebe
ich noch Kokosraspeln rein und ich
schlage das jetzt mit dem
schneebesenaufsatz erstmal mit langsamer
Geschwindigkeit so dass sich das
verbindet heute hat die Tür nicht auf zu
klingeln ja du bist ja ne so ich frag
erstmal auf niedriger Geschwindigkeit so
dass ich alles miteinander verbindet und
dann werde ich immer schneller und füge
währenddessen während des stinkt
Sahnefest dazu einfach für die gewisse
Festigkeit und ganz zum Schluss noch
Kokosraspeln und dann ist die Creme auch
schon fertig
[Musik]
so als nächstes machen wir unsere
Buttercreme aus nur zwei Zutaten bzw
eine optionale dritte Zutat und dann
nehme ich jetzt einfach ganz ganz weiche
Butter die habe ich habe alle meine
tagesschaue jetzt schon benutzt die habe
ich aus dem Kühlschrank genommen
ungefähr zwei Stunden vorab gebe ich
jetzt hier mit rein und Butter verändert
sowohl Geschmack als auch aussehen wenn
ihr sie lang genug schlagt das sage ich
immer wieder weil viele abgeturnt sind
von mutter-creme aber man muss einfach
sagen also außen einstreichen um die
Deko kann man einfach am allerbesten mit
Buttercreme da bringt auch keine
Mascarpone was und deswegen Schleich das
jetzt in der Küchenmaschine wenn ihr
eine leistungsstarke Küchenmaschine habt
so die Beine dann reichen eigentlich
zwei Minuten aber wenn jetzt ein
Handrührer hat oder eine andere
Küchenmaschine könnte es schon sein dass
jeder sieben acht Minuten Langschlag
also ich sage das jetzt zwei Minuten
lang und gebe dann Milchmädchen bzw für
zuckerte Kondensmilch dazu viele kennen
das als Milchmädchen dann schlage ich
das hier mit noch mal weitere zwei bis
drei Minuten und die optionale dritte
Zutat ist Vanilleextrakt würde ich auf
jeden Fall mit reingeben schmeckt
einfach viel viel besser und ganz zum
Schluss färbe ich das dann rot ein
[Musik]
so kleiner Nachtrag nicht alles rot
färben sondern die Hälfte also nehmen
die Hälfte der Creme ich habe jetzt hier
aus meinem Shop Fuchsien rot genommen
guckt euch mal diese Farbe an ich finde
die sieht so gut aus und die andere
Hälfte da habe ich Pistazien grün
genommen und ich finde das ist die
perfekte Farbe das ist einfach der
perfekte Grünton so das gebe ich jetzt
aber auch noch mal kurz an die Seite
jetzt nicht in den Kühlschrank stellen
sondern einfach auf Zimmertemperatur
lagern bis ihr das braucht wir machen
jetzt erstmal weiter mit unserem Boden
der ist hier komplett abgekühlt und
jetzt muss ich erstmal den Tortenring
entfernen den könnt ihr sie einfach so
abnehmen sonst reißt ihr euch da was am
Rand weg ich nehme mir mein langes
tortenringmesser ihr kennt
wahrscheinlich alle das hier das benutze
ich auch für meinen Backrahmen das ist
aber zu kurz daher haben wir dieses
lange hier entwickelt extra für solche
Fälle jetzt geht ihr mit der feinen
Klinge einmal am Rand entlang und dann
löst die quasi schon mal den Boden vom
Ring
geht mit allen unbeschichteten Formen
übrigens so und dann könnt ihr einfach
den Tortenring runter nehmen und den
Boden durchschneiden also wir haben die
Form so gut vorbereitet das ist so fest
ist jetzt das Backpapier
einmal das Backpapier am besten
ausbreiten so und dann könnt ihr nämlich
auch den Ring ganz einfach entfernen so
schöne Farbe
so sehr sehr schöne Farbe
[Musik]
und ich teile den jetzt zweimal durch
damit ich drei Böden habe dann nehme ich
einfach meine tortensäge die ist
stufenlos verstellbar das ist das coole
weil jeder Boden backt halt individuell
hoch und dann könnt ihr ganz einfach
ohne ohne eine feste Stufe vorgegeben zu
bekommen einfach Millimeter genau das
ganze jetzt ausmessen durch drei Teilen
und dann die Böden alle gleichmäßig
durchschneiden
[Musik]
also wie ihr hört hört ihr nichts
es ist einfach so gewesen dass wir bei
meiner tortensäge die ist ja schon mega
gut weil die hat halt eine echte
sägezahnklinge und kann selbst nussböden
frische Böden etc komplett
durchschneiden ohne dass da irgendwie
irgendwas schief läuft
ich stehe überhaupt nicht auf diese
grünen an ich stehe gar nicht auf diese
drahtsegen denn ihr müsst euch mal
vorstellen warum gibt es warum gibt es
Ersatzrad das zeigt doch schon dass dass
man voraus sagt dass dieses Produkt
dieses Draht einfach immer kaputt gehen
würde ist ja kein Ersatzrad geben es
gibt keinen Ersatz keine Ersatzklinge
für meine tortensäge weil es ist einfach
das wird nicht kaputt gehen aber was uns
aufgefallen ist und was nicht gut war
das zeige ich euch jetzt also mal
realtalk es ist schon fast perfektes
Produkt aber das hier
das hat uns immer so ein bisschen nervös
gemacht daher war die Idee einfach hier
so schwarze Noppen noch dran zu tun
damit einfach dieses Geräusch nicht mehr
kommt und ihr also meine Oberfläche ist
sehr robust das ist Naturstein darf man
auch drauf kratzen aber nicht jeder hat
ja sowas als Oberfläche und daher ist
das auch schonender für eure Oberflächen
mal so ein bisschen ausgeschweift hier
und ein bisschen Produkt Talk gemacht
aber es ist ja auch mal ganz interessant
oder ich werde übrigens die Oberfläche
auch noch mal gerade abschneiden auch
Opal auch wenn ich eigentlich nicht
müsste aber ich will einfach komplett
gerade haben daher werde ich den kleinen
Mini Hobel soll ich mal auch noch mal
gerade wegschneiden
[Musik]
so jetzt geht eigentlich alles sehr sehr
schnell ich habe jetzt hier schon mal
den ersten Boden auf eine hübsche
Tortenplatte gelegt nehme ich mir wieder
den Ring von gerade
so erst backen wir darin und dann
benutzen wir den einfach damit alles
schön gerade und stabil ist
so einmal zumachen und jetzt nehmen wir
uns von der Kokoscreme die Hälfte und
geben das hier auf dem Boden dann kommt
einfach der zweite Boden drauf und dann
die restliche Creme ihr dürft euch gerne
noch minimal Creme aufbewahren einfach
um ganz oben am Ende so ein bisschen
noch mal einzustreichen einfach als
Schutz damit uns die Böden nicht
austrocknen dann nehmen wir einfach was
von der feuchten Creme aber da reichen
echt so zwei maximal drei Esslöffel dass
ihr euch die einfach auch privat für
ganz oben
[Musik]
ich sage jetzt geht alles ganz schnell
wir können direkt weitermachen
normalerweise kennt ihr das von mir das
eine Kühlzeit notwendig ist nach dem
Befüllen aber diese Mascarpone sahne
Creme heute ist schon sehr sehr fest es
sei denn es ist so doof es sei denn ihr
macht die Torte mitten im Sommer aber
warum solltet ihr dann fließt zu euch
manchmal weg also ich merke das auch
richtig im Winter da geht's immer sehr
sehr gut die sind schön fest so jetzt
bin ich einmal noch mal mit dem
Tortenring Messer entlang gefahren jetzt
kommt der Tortenring ab der hat uns
jetzt geholfen dass alles schön akkurat
gerade ist
so und jetzt verstreichen wir achtet
nicht auf hier oben das wird gleich
alles hübsch jetzt verstreichen wir
erstmal die Seiten mit der hübschen
roten Buttercreme ich nehme jetzt hier
noch mal meine drehbare Tortenplatte
einfach weil ich dann ja das ganze schön
glatt und viel glatter verstreichen kann
als wenn ich da jetzt keine Platte unten
drunter hätte das nervt mich hier ein
bisschen ich muss das hier ein bisschen
gerade machen
aber ihr müsst jetzt nicht
perfektionistisch sein weil da kommt
gleich ihr noch was drauf also alles
ganz entspannt so und jetzt macht ihr
das folgendermaßen einfach so ein
bisschen von der Buttercreme ich liebe
die Konsistenz übrigens gerade einfach
hier ein bisschen was an den Rand geben
ganz unordentlich und dann nimmt ihr
euch gleich eine Teigkarte und in
drehenden Bewegungen könnt ihr das schön
glatt verstreichen vielleicht brauchen
wir sogar nur eine Schicht manchmal
mache ich ja die erste Schicht zur
krümelbindung gerade weil der Boden
jetzt auch so super frisch ist aber
vielleicht reicht sogar auch nur eine
für sogar noch schneller fertig heute
[Musik]
so jetzt kommt die erste Kühlzeit denn
die Buttercreme soll richtig fest werden
damit ich gleich in aller Ruhe meinen
Grip runter fließen lassen kann und die
grüne Buttercreme die auch auf
Zimmertemperatur stehen lassen also 20
maximal 30 Minuten kühlt die jetzt und
in der Zwischenzeit gebe ich mir die
grüne Buttercreme einfach in den
Spritzbeutel mit einer großen Tülle und
dann kommt der super super spaßige Teil
mit dem drip und der Deko ist klar
[Musik]
so die Torte ist gekühlt ihr erkennt es
daran dass wenn die anfasst dann nicht
an den Fingern kleben bleibt also ist
die fest genug dass wir den drip jetzt
drüber geben können ich nehme jetzt für
den drip mein cake Grip weil der einfach
komplett weiß ist ich kann euch
alternativ falls ihr den gerade nicht da
habt auch reinschreiben welches
Verhältnis an weißer Kuvertüre mit ähm
was nimmt er mit Kokosöl was du davon
Verhältnis nehmen müsst aber ich muss
ehrlich sagen dann habt ihr halt so ein
b-ton und es sieht einfach hübscher aus
wenn es komplett weiß ist und nicht
beige und das macht jetzt folgendermaßen
einfach den Deckel abschrauben und dann
bei 600 oder maximal 900 Watt für
ungefähr eine Minute bis anderthalb in
die Mikrowelle geben dann merkt ihr dass
die Schokolade einfach flüssig wird dann
den Deckel wieder anschrauben und dann
könnt ihr das einfach verwenden und ihr
könnt immer wieder verwenden also wenn
es dann hart wird und ihr habt noch was
übrig einfach immer wieder erwärmen beim
nächsten tortenprojekt und dann machen
wir gemeinsam den Cake Grip und
anschließend dekorieren wir noch mit der
grünen Buttercreme
[Musik]
ich habe mich jetzt dazu entschieden an
die Seite den Cake Club runter fließen
zu lassen und die Oberfläche nicht mit
dem cake Grip voll zu machen sondern ich
habe ja noch ein bisschen Buttercreme
übrig und da habe ich jetzt einfach in
die Mitte so ein bisschen rote
Buttercreme eingestrichen damit von oben
man schaut dass der Kontrast immer noch
rot und grün ist und hier außen herum
habe ich mir gar nicht so viel Mühe
gegeben weil jetzt kommt sowieso unser
Kranz zum Einsatz das wird so ein
schöner Kranz mit einer rosentülle und
da könnt ihr am besten ich habe dich
lieb immer gerne vorher einmal und mir
auch sicher zu gehen dass mir das Design
gefällt dann könnt ihr jetzt von innen
nach außen gehen und wichtig ist den
Spritzbeutel einfach komplett gerade
runterzuhalten also nicht schräg sondern
komplett gerade und ähm Plan ist es
jetzt aus dem relativ großes Rosen zu
spritzen und innen dann noch mal eine
Bahn kleine Rosen
[Musik]
so fertig ist meine Weihnachtstorte auch
wenn ich zum Beispiel kein Weihnachten
Feier finde ich es einfach total schön
diese Idee an euch weiterzugeben es gibt
der Energie Community einfach kunterbunt
alle möglichen Menschen und daher denke
ich mir das einfach eine schöne
Inspiration für euch und wenn ich das
jetzt so auf dem Tisch stehen sehen
würde würde ich sagen boah die ruft
schon richtig richtig nach dem Winter
und Weihnachten allein die Farben ich
möchte es gerne noch so ein bisschen
durchkühlen lassen also es reicht wenn
ihr die jetzt wirklich 15 Minuten noch
mal durchkühlen lassen dann ist sie
sofort Verzehr bereit aber vielleicht
habe ich ja Glück und erwischt nur noch
den haben sie morgen zum test test und
dann können wir die zusammen für euch
probieren daher sage ich mal bis später
und dann sehen wir uns im Facebook
wieder
[Musik]
und also ganz ehrlich wenn ich so
betrachtet ich würde direkt sagen
Weihnachtskuchen oder wegen den Farben
ja
Santa clauses
richtig schön ich habe mich voll gefreut
auf den Anschnitt der ist einfach schön
also ich glaube die die Weihnachten
feiern das auf jeden Fall das auf dem
Tisch habe ich schon gesagt dass
man
eine Buttercreme gearbeitet probiere ich
schon mal aber es ist nicht komplett
eingestellt also komplett eingestrichen
und gefühlt mit Buttercreme daher eine
gute Mischung also eigentlich sieht
immer grün immer so verdor
Kokosraspeln sind drin also
geschmacklich ist voll lecker aber die
kokosrasten sind tatsächlich in der
weißen Creme und der Boden ist mein
fluffiger vanillebiskuit den magst du
doch so sehr immer wenn wir Reste hatten
die Kombi zwischen der Creme und der
Boden ich finde das so als ob
wirklich sehr lecker und Vanille kommt
auch gut raus also ich persönlich auf
jeden Fall
aber weiß ich auch cool finde
Referat Schule früher
in einer Klasse und ich sag's euch dies
ist kein gutes Vorbild aber ich habe
meine Referate immer in der Nacht vorher
und in der Bahn Richtung Schule
vorbereitet ich habe immer einen von
zwei bekommen und dann haben wir immer
der hat sich voll ins Zeug gelegt und
das waren dann eher so das ist auch gute
Noten gehabt aber oft waren es auch so
voll unberechtigt meine Tür oder so
alles gedacht haben hey das war cool
dieser würde haben seine
falls wir damals so ein Dream Team waren
waren auch mal voll die besten Freunde
und so da hatten wir auch einige die das
so nicht ausstehen konnten weiß ich ich
weiß nicht es gibt doch manchmal so bin
ich ich weiß auch nicht auf jeden Fall
Gast
du die Torte richtig cool gemacht ich
habe jetzt voll den Faden verloren und
ich warte richtig schön geschmacklich
auch top bei dir auch nicht süß ist
kannst du hier noch mal so rein und gebe
ich hin ich meine dass sie zu süß ist
also man kann
das voll die Kalorien
voll süß und Zucker aber von dir probier
mal bitte die Buttercreme er probiert
sie pur ich will einfach nur dass du mir
sagst wirklich er ehrliche Meinung wie
findest du die Buttercreme das ist
Butter ist
[Musik]
aufschlagen und in Verbindung mit der
mit der zuckerten Kondens mit es
schmeckt überhaupt nicht nach Butter
überhaupt nicht voll lecker
ich würde mal sagen lassen euch jetzt
mal machen das Ganze nach Leute ich will
eure Fotos sehen
über Instagram
eure Fotos von dieser genialen Torte und
auf jeden Fall Weihnachten
und abonniert doch mein wollte ich was
habe ich noch was gesagt unseren Kanal
kostenlos wenn ihr keine Rezepte mehr
verpassen möchtet denn ich bin Kiki und
du willst
ach so
wie früher
[Musik]